my name is tracy rabin and i'm director
of the office of global health in the
department of internal medicine at the
yale school of medicine
i'm also the co-director of the yigh
global health ethics program
and it is truly an honor today to be
able to introduce you to the featured
speaker for our very special yigh
event dr olusoji at day
dr adey's career accomplishments are
truly impressive
before i share a bit of his background i
want to summarize by saying that if the
true measure of our successes are the
number of lives that have been changed
for the better because of one's efforts
both direct and indirect then he is
among our times most imminent
dr adey is currently the president of
resilient health systems a washington
dc-based policy analysis and advisory
systems firm services firm and he's also
a senior associate at the johns hopkins
bloomberg school of public health
over the course of his more than 30-year
career focusing on global health policy
he has held leadership positions with
the world bank world health organization
unaids the nigerian federal ministry of
health and was the founding director of
the affordable medicines facility
malaria a public-private partnership
hosted by the global fund to fight aids
tuberculosis and malaria
with a focus on improving the structure
and function of health systems these
positions have allowed him truly to
touch every region of the world
born in nigeria dr adey earned his
bachelor's in medical degrees from the
university of isei and subsequently
received a master of community health
from the liverpool school of tropical
medicine
a master of business administration from
imperial college london university of
london
and ultimately his doctor of public
health from the johns hopkins university
when we spoke a few weeks ago he shared
that it was his early work as a
physician that motivated him to pursue
additional training and to set off on
this very unique journey
in that role he had the personal
experience of seeing the devastating
impact that financial policies
influenced by national priorities and
international donors had on patients and
the health system
and as he told me i wanted to be in a
position to influence policy rather than
being on the receiving end
along those lines he had also shared the
perspective that it's important for
those of us who seek global health
careers to embark on this journey for
reasons that are personally meaningful
as this is what will stiffen the spine
and keep us moving forward in the face
of adversity
i'm certain that this sense of purpose
will come through in today's
conversation and i look forward to the
other lessons that he has to share with
us
dr adey thank you so much for joining us
here today
i'll turn the podium over now to the
moderator for today's q a session my
yale school of public health colleague
rafael perez escamilla professor of
public health and director of the office
of public health practice and the global
health concentration looking forward to
a very robust conversation
thank you so very much tracy for your
kind introduction
and soji what an honor to be able to
serve as a host
today for you to share with our audience
why
did you decide
to
take the somewhat painful step of
writing a book to actually share your
experiences in global health what is the
niche that you
tried to
position your book
when you decided to write it
thank you very much uh tracy for your
kind introduction and raphael and your
team for this opportunity to have this
conversation
uh you refer to the process of writing
the book as painful that's true
i think there are two other dimensions
to it one is it was actually a joy
because it was so
uh it was so instructive uh right in the
book
and this is the book i wish i had
when i was 25
and i've written it several times in my
mind but i finally had an opportunity to
put it on paper
so what is the motivation uh behind the
book
the ultimate motivation is for those of
us who are engaged in public health
whether as
policy makers
as analysts
as financiers or influencers
that we step back
re-examine the roots
of global health take stock
of what has worked well and importantly
honestly appraise
why it is so unhappy today why global
health is so unhappy
but that we do so not because we want to
then slump
into negativity that nothing can ever
improve
also we do so with a renewed sense of
purpose
and clear-eyed optimism that we can make
it better
that is the ultimate purpose of the book
and which is why
my favorite sentence
in the book is actually the last
sentence in the book
which says a brighter future is possible
thank you very much er sergey and
i
do want to share with you and the
audience that
i work for three years in your beautiful
country of nigeria in the state of
kaduna
with a maternal infant and young child
feeding the project
and through that project
i learned
on the one hand how complex nigeria
was and is
from
political economic
systems a healthcare systems education
systems point of view but at the same
time i also learned about
the incredibly rich culture and
traditions
and
quite frankly you know experiences that
the country
has had over
many many decades now trying to
improve
a number of
healthcare outcomes that are not only
unique to nigeria but also
to the rest the rest of
of the world so can you tell us a little
bit about how
having been born raised in nigeria
actually ended up
informing your decision to end up
working in the field of global health to
do it from a capacity building
perspective
and lastly what
have you learned
from your own experience with regards to
the legacy of colonialism and
neocolonialism on current global health
inequities
thanks raphael and now that i know
you're my fellow nigerian i think
one of these days you and i should get
together and
share a glass of palm wine which i'm
sure you had when you were in the
country
but on the topic at hand
in hindsight it's all very clear now in
hindsight
uh much of what i do is influenced by
my own early experiences and some form
the formative years uh in nigeria
excuse me
my mother is a retired businesswoman
my father was a nurse so i saw quite a
few
uh
cases that he treated early on and
there's one that sticks in my mind
he was extracting guinea worm from uh
somebody's
leg and that was quite impressive
uh for a five or six year old uh to
witness
but
in the larger social context
i grew up in a society with its own very
powerful narrative i i was born in oyo
which is the capital of an old empire
that predated
uh many of the
uh countries were talking about it
predated the united states for example
and oyo is called the land of
the god of thunder so it was we had a
very strong sense of our own social
identity
i also did my undergraduate years in
nigeria
and i went to medical school there too
and what i experienced there was
the power of one of education
and the stresses
that poverty can put on those who cannot
afford the health care that they need i
think that was a very
uh searing experience to witness as a
young physician when i witnessed that
they also come from a background in
which we were taught from day one
that
you have to do something about the world
around you you're not just going to
complain about it
so i opted to go into a public health
policy as a result
of that
well when i look back
now uh
i think
two or three things stand out to me
the importance of a sense of purpose
this is for
positive reasons because it keeps us
going it keeps it keeps us going on a
day-to-day basis
it also makes us more resilient to
the various ups and downs that we
experience in the course of a career in
global health
a second one is to be
to pay extra attention to the realities
of people with whom we work in low and
lower middle income countries
they have their own narratives
they may not have studied epidemiology
and biostatistics
and health economics
and so some of the things they do and
some of the ways they go about things
may not make sense
to somebody who has just parachuted in
from the global nerve
but if one
has
a certain degree of humility and a
willingness to learn
then it becomes possible to understand
their reality it becomes possible
to engage with them in a very effective
way and it becomes possible
uh for
the programs on which we work the
analysis that we do to actually have a
multiplier effect
thank you sergey and as part of the
subtitle of your book
you list investing amidst pandemics deny
a lot of evidence and neo-dependency can
you talk to us a little bit about the
what do you mean by denial of evidence
as well as neo-dependency and why are
those important to understand and
address
thank you raphael
uh
in our profession
in public health policy
uh one of the tenets uh is to
rigorously base our recommendations on
our programs
on
scientific analysis
of course you adapt
from country to country and even within
countries so as to be viable during
implementation
and i think this is great it's central
to what we do is central to our
professional credibility
however if you look at the world around
us in global health
that premise does not always hold up so
let me answer your question directly
one of the things about which i've been
most impressed in my career is the
extent to which
evidence is swept aside when it does not
meet
uh the preferences of powerful actors in
global health
there are many examples of those
uh
and i i refer to a few in the book but
the one that is really central
to the illustration in the book is that
of the united states agency for
international development usaid
and the u.s president's malaria
initiative uspmi
this is concerning
access to malaria medicines for people
in low-income countries
despite
rigorous evaluation of a pilot program
that in fact the approach taken was
working
usaid and uspmi
did everything they could to derail that
program they bullied any entity that did
not subscribe to their point of view
and they successfully bullied the global
fund to fight htb and malaria
into discontinuing that program
now i'm not telling you any state
secrets it just happens that i led that
enterprise so i had a front row seat
into what happened
so this is an instance in which usaid
and uspmi
simply obliterated a program that was
demonstrably on the path to saving many
lives in low and lower middle income
countries because it does not confirm
to their preferences and because if it
worked my understanding
since it was demonstrated to be working
it was a threat
to the way usaid does its business which
is to give hundreds of millions of
dollars contracts
to american-based contractors
and if that program were expanded
and institutionalized as it should have
been
that will really
put uscid's business model in turmoil so
that is a prime example
of
denial of evidence as you state by the
way
that at the time that program was
evaluated it was probably the most
rigorously evaluated large program
in global health around that time
now
on new dependency
let's
be upfront about one item which is that
colonialism was extremely bad there is
no other way to describe it
crimes against humanity were committed
by european powers
and by those who enslaved africans there
is no qualifying it period
and it is also true that the effects of
colonialism are still with us
uh in terms of the fact that the
colonized societies even though they are
not politically independent the wound
endures in terms of their social
policies and
and
the devastation that was raped over the
years
having said that
my proposition in the book
is that a greater problem a problem that
is greater than
neocolonialism and the lasting effect of
colonialism is the what i call new
dependency
that's the dependency or the the
perpetual dependency
of many countries in the global south on
the global north
and this is manifested clearly but not
only
in the way foreign aid is mediated by
several institutions
and in the way those countries
is i see they really do not want to
graduate from being dependent on the
global north
and that if this is going to be turned
around
then there needs to be a fundamental
change
such that such that those countries
become
more reliant on their own revenues on
their own domestic resources
and that they demonstrate what i would
call
increasingly self-financed assertiveness
that really is the core of it so while
the perennial the bad effects of
colonialism endure
the central problem uh
as i understand it is actually that of
new dependence
and that leads to several
recommendations in the book
thank you very much sergey and i do want
to
ask the audience to please take
opportunity
of they take this opportunity to engage
with dr soji
on
some questions and answers
based on these
very thought-provoking and important
statements that he that he's making
so
um raphael we do have one question that
came in please please um
and the question is how do
we as students and staff at yale or
other powerful institutions in the
global north
um advocate and work in mitigating the
negative effects of neo-colonialism and
global health
wow
[Music]
that's a trillion dollar question and a
great one
i think before advocating my sense of it
is to
be very deeply aware of
the narrative around us
and how
those effects of neocolonialism are
modulated in real life
so
it starts with the the causes in those
schools
uh my sense is that
while
epidemiology and biostatistics and the
behavioral sciences and health economics
remain
central and core to a rigorous
curriculum in public health for example
it is important
to pay equally serious attention
to
political analysis
to the political economy
of global health
and to what i will call influencing
policies and enabling change
so that we do not go into a highly
political situation
with purely technocratic tools
that assume
that if we just get our regressions
right then everything will fall in place
that's the first one
the second step
is taking the time and making a serious
effort
to understand the social political
narrative and the social political
realities
of the countries in which we seek to
operate let me share an example that is
in the book
in this book
global health and practice
i lived in ethiopia many years ago
as a young
professional working with the world
health organization
and
i was there during the war that ended in
1991.
one of the things that i observed
was that many very senior technical
experts
who had been trained in
really high class
high quality schools the likes of yale
and all the others
they will come into the country and
a number of them will look at their
counterparts and they will see
the stereotypical poor citizen
of a poor country or poor official an
official of a poor country that needed
help
and they promptly
proceeded to prescribe solutions
to those officials
now they were doing so with the best of
technical or technocratic intentions if
i may use that phrase
the problem was it did not fit the
narrative of those officials because the
officials looked in the mirror
and they saw the descendants
of those who won the battle of edward
when the ethiopians defeated the
italians and this was
you know
in in addition to that
they remember the association between
the queen of shiva and king solomon
so when they looked in the mirror they
saw
the descendants of a very proud people
and you can just imagine how
these two narratives collided
and that limited the effectiveness of
those europeans and not americans
to whom i referred so taking the time to
truly understand the narrative
and the social political dynamics of the
people with whom you're engaging is key
a third one is to be very clear in terms
of what we're optimizing for
if we're optimizing for a small pilot
project to demonstrate effect in a
population of 500 people or 5 000 people
in one sub district it's a legitimate
thing to do
but if
our aim
is to engage with and influence what
happens all across a very large country
like pakistan or the democratic republic
of congo or all of nicaragua
just society examples from different
parts of the world
then
we need to understand that we're engaged
in an enterprise that is substantially
political
and proceed as such
thank you very much sergey and and we're
doing our best at the yale school of
public health to actually
update or develop
new courses
to very strongly emphasize
the points that you just made about
how
yes a small-scale efficacy trials or
studies are important
but the ability to transfer that
a crucial
knowledge for the survival and healthy
development of human beings into
large-scale sustainable operations is is
another ballgame and and really requires
a deep understanding of
the history the political the
economic the social systems in the
countries and i found very rapidly in in
kaduna in in nigeria and really
understanding how powerful
the
community
structures are and how impossible it is
to scale up anything if there is no
support from
you know the
community leaders
for those projects to end up being
implemented
successfully on the ground so so i
really want to urge you know the
audience to to read this
a very important
book on on global health practice
because it really comes from
what we i like to call a global a huge
global health practice scholar that has
been there has has done that and has
been able to
look at the global health challenges
from from many different angles over
over several
over several decades so please keep on
on sharing with yours with us your your
very insightful
questions
so moving on to the next part of the of
the discussion is so as as you know
a
given the context of the uncertainty
with the call with a 19 pandemic the
likelihood that
it's not going to be the last uh
probably at least in my
in in my lifetime
some of our our students even our
faculty are a little bit anxious about
you know how how the future jobs in
global health are going to look like
which are the skills that
the future
global health professionals should have
to be
to be successful doing doing their work
so can you share with us the
contributions from your excellent book
towards
institutions like yale
to
convey to the faculty to the students in
terms of what they should be focusing on
to really strive to become
[Music]
you know really key
global health practitioners moving
forward
thanks rafael i think the probably
probably the single most important
question to ask oneself is
how can i be most useful
and that may sound so obvious but i
think a failure to
closely uh reflect on that uh question
might lead to a lot of frustration so if
one approaches it from the point of
being useful
then it means go where the problems are
and
be equipped with the tools
to help better understand
those problems
and
to help
formulate
workable solutions to those problems
even if
they are not the ideal
solutions from a purely theoretical
point of view so let's let's compact
this
in terms of being useful
uh perhaps
because of the uh
copy 19 pandemic and the subsequent
attention
to global health
for people younger colleagues who are
about to go into the field
i i would say
you're actually very fortunate because
you don't have to explain to anybody
what public health is well you don't
have to explain to most people what
public health is or why it is so
important not everybody gets it
okay
in order to be useful i think uh
one also needs to figure out which niche
to occupy or to seek to occupy initially
so
is it to be an analyst
helping to better understand the scale
the dynamics of health problems
uh is it to be primarily
a doer and i'm not suggesting that those
are very different they're they're
intertwined
in which case it will make sense to seek
opportunities
in entities
implementing programs in challenging
situations
and to good intention of learning
or is it to be uh primarily in an
advocacy position again that's not
separate from being an analyst or a doer
i'm just trying to simplify
and that's okay too
and then it means understanding whether
one is seeking to be an analyst
in terms of
bearing witness
which has its place
or whether one seeks to go beyond
bearing witness
and nudging
rich and powerful entities
to do better
by the developing countries or nudging
the rulers of developing countries to do
better by their own
societies
one final note on that is
is overriding
uh charles houston who was the professor
of
thurgood marshall
at the howard university law school
which is just a mile from where i'm
speaking in washington dc
had an injunction for his students
and he said it was not sufficient to be
a lawyer they also had to be social
engineers
otherwise they were just being parasites
i think that applies to people in global
public health too
in different ways
it's important to be to have the mindset
of a social engineer
an analytically regarded social engineer
otherwise
one might unwittingly become a parasite
so in sum
the future is bright for those entering
global health there are just so many
challenges waiting to be tackled and
please go forth and be useful
thank you very much for for such an an
inspiring
answer
and
abell
is
is also asking
given the complex skills essentially
that are that are needed here
to succeed in
in the field of global health it how you
how do you overcome
the challenges
that inevitably you know you're going to
find as an early career professional
what what did you do
to overcome those challenges yourself
uh what words of wisdom your book has
to offer to to appeal and colleagues
well i really i really appreciate your
your question this is abel galetta if i
if i'm i'm looking at the yes
the chat box great question
i think it's important to have uh good
mentors because when you are starting
out
there are many things that are just
so new and they can be confusing and
sometimes you might
struggle with how to prioritize and what
to filter out
so having a mentor or a set of mentors
in my view is really important
a second one is
approaching
global health or the mindset that
every obstacle is an opportunity to
learn and get better and grow i think
those two are really uh are fun
they're fundamental
uh
yeah those are the those are the two key
ones
that i would say uh early on finding
having good mentors and approaching
obstacles
uh from the perspective of of learning i
think those are really those are
critical yes thank you sergey very much
and then
linking this somewhat to the previous
statement that you made about
you know the u.s agency for
international development which is as we
know is not unique to usaid you know
it's it's it's a a very common situation
with
international aid agencies
and
the fact that they all have their
agendas their priorities and
sometimes
from almost overnight they change and
countries that are being affected by
huge problems and working of them for
decades do not have a say on when and
how
those pivot points
those pivot points happen
so
several of my students you know have
asked me in the past
is there any hope that i can actually
work for an agency like that and change
it from the inside out
if i choose not to work in an agency
like that then where am i going to work
where am i going to be able to
to make a difference and i get a very
well your important point about
the advocacy
and grassroots work and and so on
but also in the in that context that
you know financial resources are needed
as well
uh to engage in large-scale
programming and and so on
and
what would you advise
our students regarding
a sense of hopelessness that some of
them have that
it's very difficult would be almost
impossible to change
the the way the key agencies
are governed the structures that they
have and and the somewhat arbitrary way
in which
that they follow to make decisions
yeah uh
if i i
i would say they are very
complex institutions
and within that complexities there are
opportunities for professionals who are
rigorous
who are discerning and who are committed
to making a difference
so
even for younger members of staff
it means
being very credible in one's own
analytical work
and developing a way of engaging with
more senior people in the institutions
to inform
their thinking
and to change the way they look at
problems
and if that change means a 25
improvement about what the the world
have done before
that's a win
to start with
but at that stage
uh for the
for the entry-level professionals it
means their span of control is
relatively narrow that's true
but over time you get a much broader and
increasingly a bigger
span of control and therefore they are
the the scope to influence decisions and
influence policies becomes even larger
so i can share a few examples with you
there's a chapter on russia in the book
and
uh yes i led the team that did that
turnaround
i also had a vice president at the time
for the for the region
uh who was supportive of the effort that
we made
so that's that's a positive uh
aspect
and
there are several other aspects uh in
which uh in which i was involved
both analytical work
and program implementation and financing
etc
so
it is not a case of black or white
that institutions are
absolutely irredeemable
i think it's the case that they're very
complex
and within that complexity there are
opportunities for public health
professionals to make a serious
difference
having said that
in terms of the macro system realigning
the macro system etc etc well that is
beyond the purview of any particular
individual in
global health or agriculture or
transportation whichever sector you you
primarily work in
uh that becomes
a political
question
uh in terms of global the global
financial architecture and that is part
of the point
in the book so please if you are
wondering
uh is it a hopeless task to work with or
in those large agencies like who the
world bank uh et cetera et cetera no it
is not there are vast opportunities
there and i will seriously encourage you
to seize those opportunities
thank you very much sergey and for the
audience please if you want to share
with
sergey any
personal experiences
working for agencies or
[Music]
or in the field your academic
institutions and so on and what have you
learned from them
we would very much welcome your
your sharing of those
of those experiences
so if i want to move on now
towards the last phase of our
conversation
which is
related
to how to maintain
initiatives how to maintain traction
how to
ensure that
the relatively few
programs that have been successfully
scaled up
across countries
essentially
keep on going and they don't they don't
they don't fall
fall back you know to the chaos that
was there before they
they emerged so in terms of
sustainability of programs what what
lessons does your work offers to us
it's a great question and perhaps is the
is the perennial question
in my experience
i think
programs become sustainable on multiple
dimensions
quite often when we talk about
sustainability we're talking about
financial sustainability and technical
sustainability both of which are highly
important
there is another dimension which is
political sustainability
and for the median leader
a program is sustainable
when
they perceived political benefits of
that program
of continuing that program or enlarging
it when they outweigh
the political risks of not continuing it
which is why it is very important
for the political leaders in societies
to be directly engaged in and to own
large programs in their own countries
it's also very important
for
the citizens of those societies
to see and feel the benefits of those
programs
if the benefits of a program are obscure
well there will be there's unlikely to
be much social mobilization behind it
but if they are visible they are
actually communicated to the public
and
the successive governments know that
these programs are actually delivering
good things
then they're more likely to at least
make an effort
to continue those programs
there's another there's a little
dimension that i would like to draw our
attention to and this is the compared to
what question
so if
you engage in a large program
and just for discussion sake
let's just say the success rate before
you went in
was
10
and you are able to take it to
60 percent obviously that's not perfect
okay you really want to hit something
much higher
all other things being equal i think it
is wise
to celebrate that improvement from 10 to
60 percent
and then seek to take it to 70
but sometimes in global public health i
have seen situations in which if it
cannot go from 10
to
100
then you have many advocates saying okay
it's a failure it's bad
so it's a binary situation
which is just so self-defeating so again
uh for all of us uh going into this
field or those who are there and seeking
to uh to make even more improvements
let's keep this in mind uh the the
compared to what question because quite
often
the counterfactual is not your uh
utopian perfection
the counter factual is actually
something that is a really bad situation
so if it's getting better
celebrate it don't be complacent don't
be satisfied but celebrate that success
and just keep pushing ahead don't
don't just throw it all away because you
cannot
achieve immediate perfection
absolutely the soldier couldn't well i
say absolutely
myself my experience i couldn't agree
more because i i really think that that
goes back to your point of the
importance of understanding that complex
causes behind
these problems
many of which
you know have been with us for centuries
you know and that
we need to be realistic as to
you know what is a temporary solution
what is a short-term technical solution
what at the end of the day would be a
real
long-term long-term solution so if
everybody is contributing
in a coordinated way i think
with either 10 cents so to speak to
improve them
it reaches a point where you know those
improvements are not that trivial
and cannot be cannot be discounted
so if pranav is savannaur
he has a very thoughtful
question for you
so how can we build a sustained a
non-partisan partisan political will and
commitment for global health financing
and he has in mind the
upcoming
funding renewals for programs like the
global fund gabby
you know the world health organization
and and so on how to how to separate
the politics from true
from the true mission of global health i
is a way i understand this question
yeah a great question uh pranav
first
politics cannot be separated from it
i think what can probably be separated
from it or what we should
make an effort to separate from is from
it is toxic politics
okay
now on the substance of
of the of the question
i think for entities like gavi and the
global fund
the real challenge as i see it
is how they will replenish to transition
and exit from what they are currently
doing in the way they are currently
doing it
so what will it take for example
such that eight years from now say in
the year 2030
the countries themselves
are the dominant financiers of those
basic health commodities and of those
basic health services
that gavi and the global fund
disproportionately finance today
so if you take a specific just a
specific example let's just zero in on
malaria
last year who
recommended widespread use of the rcss
malaria vaccine the first time it's done
that for a malaria vaccine a life skill
and normally one will expect that since
this disease has been around for
millennia and is such a big problem
the leaders of the countries
will
lead
and commit to funding the purchase of
those vaccines predominantly by
themselves
instead what happened was that gavi
announced that it was going to commit i
think about 156 million dollars over the
next few years to those vaccines
now for is a child who gets that vaccine
in
zambia or liberia or wherever is that a
bad thing no
it's a good thing
the problem is the following
garvey was substituting itself again
for the leadership
domestic leadership in those countries
and that was very poor judgment on the
part of gavi
okay
still on malaria
the very last estimates from the world
malaria report published by who
indicate that
two-thirds
of the expenditures of malaria control
and elimination
come from external sources that's
two-thirds 67 percent
so
this needs to change cannot have a
situation where
permanently
there is dependency on external
financiers so
for replenishment it should be
replenishment for transition not
replenishment for self-perpetuation
that's the real key
here that is uh that i really want to uh
i really want to have on so that's that
applies to global fund and um and gavi
as for who
i really am not convinced that a
replenishment model is the right way to
finance who
is the central
health leadership agency the technical
normative agency as well
and it seems to me that
having that core financing sorted out is
key
[Music]
i don't think that also means who should
be responsible for everything or try to
do everything under the sun in health
it does not mean the bhu has to attend
every single meeting in every every
single village
uh on health
so
there's a
there's a case to be made
for concentrating
uh
the effort on who on
some core functions
and for funding them well from through
assessed contributions to the regular
budget not extra budgetary allocation
back to you rafael yes wow
i think we could stay here for three
hours
speaking speaking speaking with you what
what an engaging
and thoughtful
conversation and i feel
like really everyone should greet
shurikoji's
soldiers but not many people have
the
very very
holistic
experience that that he
that he has in in global health
sumaira at parsada
wants to know wants to thank you very
much
for
your talk she finds it very
inspiring she just went to amazon and
order your book so that so that you know
and she can't
read she can't wait to read it so
i'm very very glad
that you you got inspired to
to do that during this conversation and
i'm sure srj will be very happy to sign
your book when you get it we can easily
arrange for that i think
so so soji to
wrap up
the
conversation on my end i i really get
your
very central message here it's loud and
clear
unless governments end up end up being
empowered to own
the
the the the systems the structures uh
you know the infrastructure that is
needed to improve
the
public health within within their
countries and to do so with equity
following human rights principles social
justice principles and so on it is very
difficult
to actually
see how
improvement can be made
on uh
on a global level
it we know that oftentimes
there is this tension between
governments feeling oh ngos know how to
do it they're really great at doing it
have them do it
ngo saying you know we cannot do this on
a national scale we cannot
keep this sustainable and oftentimes to
me becomes an absurd either or argument
i i really think that there is a very
special place for ngos as part of
of a new global health
governance system but at the same time
there is absolutely no reason why they
cannot be
part of a government strategy when the
government's own
you know the
the the the programs the policies and so
on to keep on working together so so
what what can do i mean do you agree
with that or not and and what can be
done to improve that
a very very interesting dynamic that i i
think needs to be addressed to
to improve much more
in public health across the globe
raphael i i think you touch on on an
important point
the
there is no viable substitute
in the medium term for
a responsible government
that leads its own that leads policies
within its own country
and works across sectors
within its own country
and that includes financing of course
but there is a difference between
public
financing on the one hand
and
public delivery on the other hand so
it's entirely possible most systems are
mixed anyway
uh it's entirely possible
for
most of the expenditure in a country
most of the health expenditure in the
country
to be to be publicly financed
but for services to be delivered by a
combination of public facilities
not-for-profit uh ngo facilities for
example and for-profit facilities who
might be contracted by government
to deliver those services or contracted
by a health insurance agency to deliver
those services
and
there is a serious role for civil
society to play in that but the ngos and
the csos if one wants to to delineate
both in terms of
keeping government honest if i may use
that expression
uh mobilizing the society and shining a
light in otherwise dark areas
but the ngos and csos
in my understanding do not substitute
for
those core
governance
policy and policy translation functions
that can only be done by government and
i will even go further and say one thing
in my experience
both the country based ngos and the
international ngos in different places
have made really serious contributions
to health service delivery including in
some very hard to reach places
at the same time
it is the case that some of the northern
ngos not all of them some of them
sometimes
unwittingly perhaps substitute try to
substitute themselves for the government
of those countries
so they don't like international
organizations to dictate policies
to countries and they are right
international organizations should not
dictate policies to the countries
but in my experience quite a few of
those ngos
would like international organizations
to dictate the ngo's preferences to the
countries
and that needs to stop
in addition to that
uh
quite a few of those international
organizations do the countries a
disservice
when they blame international financing
institutions for everything
because that infantilizes the
governments of those low and lower
middle income countries
it's as if the governments cannot think
for themselves they cannot make
decisions for themselves and it becomes
very convenient to just blame everything
on outsiders
so in that regard
i think
quite a few of the
large northern ngos
need to do some introspection
and avoid a situation in which
they position themselves as if they are
the legitimate representatives
of large pop those light populations in
low and lower middle income countries
they are not and they cannot substitute
for those people
um
i also want to thank
our colleagues who have sent uh
text messages uh i think uh schedule
also thanks for getting the book and i
look forward to engaging with you all uh
please feel free to uh join me on
twitter
if i can squeeze in one last question
and i apologize for those that i cannot
ask your questions but but i think this
is a wonderful one to wrap this
conversation up and it comes from it
the jazza and it's about
what does the future call for
the healthcare systems you know
at the end of the day
as it fija states
in sub-saharan africa currently almost
no country meets the world bank and
double cho benchmarks for universal
health coverage following the
sdg
sdgs 2030 and in that context of what
has just happened or is happening with
kovite 19
what is the future for for healthcare
system strengthening or for data gender
it's a great question on which to to
wrap up i agree with you i think the
covet 19 has been a clarifier or it is
the glory clarifier it's not yet over
and it's brought a lot of stress on
societies
on the positive side it has also made
clear the importance of self-reliance by
countries of the global south
because what has happened during covet
is you realize when kovitz struck
let's face it
the message from the global north was
look you are on your own
so what does this mean
it means the global cell needs to face
its reality when it comes to universal
health coverage nobody is going to
nobody from outside
is going to solve it for them
so
my mind the way to approach this
is what has already been described as
progressive universalism
start with an emphasis on a core of
essential services
what some people refer to as essential
package of services for essential health
package
and try to get this to the whole
population
i think that is really key
uh in all our conversations so that's
number one
a second uh pillar of this in terms of
what of the how to finance it
is to move away from systems in which
many countries
a large proportion of financing comes
from
private out of pocket expenditures
which is very regressive it's not
equitable it causes financial hardship
and to move more towards
publicly financed
health systems
but that also means doing better in
terms of domestic tax collection
many of the countries do very poorly in
terms of collecting their own taxes
these are two of the pillars not all not
all these are two of the pillars
required to make progress towards uh
universal health coverage there's a
paper that i wrote about four years ago
with
some colleagues we called it the
the economic transition of health and i
think we we try to unpack that we
anticipated uh some of these constraints
uh that have now arisen a great question
education
well on that note please
join me in
warmly thanking soji for the
the wonderful contribution he has made
through his career crystallized in his
book and for agreeing to have this
wonderful conversation with us today
thank you very very much soji
thank you rafael and colleagues thanks
everybody i really appreciate this
discussion with you thank you thank you